all right then the portal service up
there and then we get a bouncy there
what no no I think if we run right
put one wait it might all right hang
over right here portals oh I cannot put
your portal back there
wait one more I put the light bridge
back up and I may need to make it smelly
again I mean speedy aegon okay I think I
got Sam uh-huh
right I think you need to run with me
though Oh again okay so you ready yes
three doing up huh go uh no maybe I
don't know
no no I was way behind - uh-oh
okay I need to get back so man I think
we did something there right but why is
there one thing here I don't know maybe
it's for spreading this yeah probably
more speed or something add another oh
[ __ ] haha yes only wants I'm starting to
think the thing with this case should be
failure
I can't Gladys is so rude hmm mmm
and wait what is this [ __ ] then why do
we need that we had sir
I'm so confused about this really why do
I have bouncy
I've um oh nothing
we should just put stuff everywhere uh
but like I am
Oh
I'm put a portal here and here ah
Oh [ __ ] Lassie ah but I've died
there's a cube here and uh we need to
get that how the heck I don't know it's
not even possible
no I know I know I know why the thing is
there right thing I'm sorry you can use
the bouncing yeah okay should I shoot
something I want to kill you punk
Oh God connection problems oh now I fell
into water
oh okay I'm officially switching the
theme of this exhibit to survival why
don't you try I need your alright what
was I doing
how that we go okay hi I'm back Devils
really weird like that crazy okay
you should read so spawn see here yes
but maybe we need CBD maybe relates to
the street first actually I wait yeah
I'm gonna speed first
no yeah committee so sorry other leg
speed first
okay no I think this again yeah oh okay
just gotta make this dumb I'm scared
like
go you can do it that's the way don't do
it that's my boy
okay ah oh did I oh dear
no it's okay we have the cube at least
uh it's good
uh-huh yeah I don't really remember how
you did it but portal here put it there
now first we're gonna need some speed
portal here and the academia one yeah
all right it's coming it's coming up
don't worry I'm not worried they're good
and then just go wait a minute you're
not that Medina I didn't make it hahaha
no I don't have the policy you know now
that how but there is oh why is it both
coming confuse face no go now go now go
now go no no no no no you missed your
chance okay I got everything it it yeah
I got it hey I'm gonna shoot going by
the time you get to then they'll be
different how we gain already wow we're
super fast well not a really fun well
what is it give us a fun man yeah you
can oh man I'm missing a whole actually
I'm only crazy since I'm going to
happening here what is that it's forest
service all walk oh ho
you always mean you know it's bad news
when someone says oh you know shits
about to yeah exactly
you're a scientist partner yeah
freakin love my loading screens power
oh we outside of the what is this she's
forced my hand
listen to me carefully we are not uh
every thousand years in the future we're
not a hundred thousand years in the
future I don't we were no it hasn't I
lie when I'm nervous
good question why am i nervous not super
drawn you're all really trouble like
triple reverse totally exactly
uh-huh do you mean where is good robots
but you can take your bullet like one
okay others I have me here la prowl
I miss Wheatley exit maybe so here we go
isn't it breakers are right there we
recycle the power hurry we need to start
your training
oh boy that I would like to where we
came from what the hell is this room for
what do you think they're supposed to do
here I'm really look they're just never
mind I found my kid way mainly room here
maybe it's a secret room now yeah it
looks like it almost but there's nothing
in there except leasing and a coffee I
like my artists to say I like my your
post looks like when you try to realize
like what is this I can't see it I like
my work oh yes say that dope ass I hate
my boss what's richest yeah
that's good Mike
but there's nothing in here yeah it
seems like it seems like nothing at all
that face where we going exit oh wait
there's another no never mind
what the hell is teres doing office yeah
the spies that are looking crazy
ah no exits is where we came from
really yeah thanks uh or maybe not
no there's yeah it is uh or is it or is
it yeah it's worth a try
let's go this we became committing wait
we need to click this the disassemblers
are fixed that was a law but they're
definitely uh-huh so we going to the
tubes I think yes wow that was weird
that was kind of cool Oh
Tara's in here
I mean white wait I love white snow
buddy what it looks like weird when
you're crouching it looks like I don't
even know sorry but what the [ __ ] are
you talking what are you aren't you
spreading the goop around there you
oh that goop we need to go I love my
goop especially I love this white sticky
stuff all over my place wait what
whoa okay and then you need a
that's okay I got
Oh deny my what do you do cut there
okay wow it's like everywhere now that's
what whatever yeah I think that's pretty
much what you're supposed to do okay
I don't know there's turrets up here
well look down Jesus there's Jesus no
just put down when you go I just said
right I need a bring be good with me uh
well oh no oh oh why didn't you warn me
you were like lookie here know what
would you do ah like anything though
and maybe I place one here and I can
no we're actually I got you it in anyway
nope um hi you can twist it yeah I got a
twist I got the twist ball hey cheering
the wrong way come on like this there we
go
okay you got to good yay yay sticky
stuff white stickers on
and yeah then you can do something I
guess I keep coming for a bit but I'm
not sure what the point that any of this
is it's beautiful
I'm fine madam an we could get it over
here we can get up there our way we do
the jumpy thing yeah I like from the
singing break campaign with tires and
whatnot
ah
what what oh it's not hitting very well
okay
yeah we're just there we go
oh sweet
it's gonna miss very alike there I don't
know why we were even using that second
day reporting just use your light blue
portal instead or wait no nevermind that
[ __ ] and I bet you Sonny okay
I'm just being editor are you sure I
can't get it up high enough there we go
oh there we go I shoot sobering oh
whatever
it's fine I can never need a Beneatha
maybe I don't know you can go through
here now and again do something up here
maybe oh crap
maybe you stopped coming in cry and I'm
crying I'm crying the spice must flow
but why do you need it to know how the
light
potentially up here and then we can make
it jumped with it maybe oh you can go
it's there
it's not fast enough anymore it's not
doing anything it's beautiful I got the
perfect beam for you it's terrible
oh hey it's a peach mistake oh okay uh
so how my vine is now it's just make the
Google faster and weak and actually do
something okay I'll make it go here
super fast like a fastest are you
impress me instead super slow what the
hell make it fall down words instead of
oh I need this portal to be actually you
got it actually I don't cut it but I
don't think you have it okay okay now I
got it now I got yes I got it
what are you ah don't don't some what me
it's still kind of slow though
why do you this my
I really don't know what you what you're
doing even say I'm trying to get some
goo up here and then on this thing and
then we can jump over you know we can
put a portal here then jump down and
then I don't know
wait maybe we change like let's let's
change that rolls like you do the flow
and I'll do that okay yeah you wanna go
you can't just ask right right right
okay okay no it's okay
ah why do we jump o we jump over here
maybe oh wow
no hang on don't man I don't wanna fall
grab that grab that blue arrived in the
flow super bad but whatever and it needs
to go up he Oh everywhere okay that's
what I was for chicken yeah it's not
good enough it's not good enough what
good ha
is that left
maybe I can grab the flow even from here
if I yeah I can grab the flow from here
I don't need you you overload my portal
phone yeah well yeah you can do it there
you go good
let's get good stuff good stuff more
full of genius oh yeah okay now I got it
and I was like everywhere yes
good right so yeah now I still don't
know what to do about that now how's
your portal here poor ear you're so
creepy like everyone then porn wait
sorry portal where and for their portal
they can get up there I want to get up
there now don't pick me down oh I'm
sorry oh right so faithful to their
portal there and then I'm the other side
of that thing they look down there but
I'm there exciting okay so I jump down
if you want to I guess like on the floor
like why why do you need a hospital
I want to come over here what but this
is momentum I want to come over this
platform oh yeah all right sure I'm
there or something no no you just like
place it somewhere I can get a jump from
okay
okay I'm not sure if this thing they're
gonna work it over all they probably
know I missed is I think no no oh yeah
mm-hmm
um nothing
are you sure everything's right thing is
you'll just fly up in the air
no I don't know what I want to do air oh
you could just make you come out here
and then we can work out and how did you
jump something yeah
this was a bit easy right now we have
one I can teleport over here if you want
to
are you already desire no oh oh you can
just go there huh yeah yeah that's
either so scary how - are you sure about
this
oh I'm on the front there I got the cube
for you here oh why is it
where are you though oh this tab I'm a
weird oh hey
it keeps down there been either huh
I got them okay
the
and then yeah I got it I got it yeah all
right maybe probably but
I can just make a bottle for you if you
want to yes oh I'll make sure that what
are you doing okay wait let's come here
no I got it I got in that I got enough
Scout again alright yes yes
and now how the heck do I go there
there's all important services over
there yes yes what I can't forget it man
yes yeah no what do you do okay
no yes that's whether money yeah let's
see what I'm going all right
oh there you go I guess super cookies
right now okay I got a good job didn't
take like five hours or something hey oh
wait I know but it's tough to Richard
speak
yeah it's really completely repainted
like that half of the time yeah exactly
I spent the last week attempting to join
one of those but we did it
okay yeah oh man oh man has been kind of
fun on this yeah
so [ __ ] [ __ ] the moral of the story is
all the humans are dead
so it looks like it's up to you two
marshmallows Mia's Papa Mia no but yes
like in marshmallows name oh I think I
need to go actually cuz I work in an
hour
signing there all right oh we can if
that's okay with you continue similar
time yeah I think we have enough for now
yeah oh cool hi
stir fun I brought with me I'm history
Langer
this is from